Speaker 1: All right, we have an absolutely
huge blockbuster story based on a report from
the House Oversight Committee, which alleges
to have uncovered evidence that Donald Trump
received millions of dollars from foreign
governments during his presidency, hid debts,
concealed losses and we're going to look at
the details of what's alleged.
This is sort of like another shoe dropping
as we expected the shoes to drop after Donald
Trump's presidency ended.
And this might actually explain why Trump
put out the statement, telling Republican
voters don't vote in 2022 and 2024, which
we covered earlier to draw attention away
from this report and to, to some degree, it
worked.
As of this morning, if you looked on Reddit
on the politics subreddit, the Trump telling
Republicans not to vote story had 70000 upvotes.
Trump's major ethics violations had 4000 upvotes,
so it quite literally is working now, both
a real stories.
But if the idea was to obfuscate, it is working
in a sense.
So let's look at this.
The House Committee on Oversight and Reform
Committee uncovers evidence that Trump concealed
millions in losses, hid debts and received
millions from foreign governments at Trump
Hotel.
Look at this.
Let's actually skip to the second part.
The document provided by GSA documents raise
new and troubling questions about Trump's
lease with the GSA and the agency's ability
to manage the former president's conflicts
of interest during his term in office when
he was effectively on both sides of the contract
as landlord and tenant.
Specifically, the committee found that President
Trump provided misleading information about
the financial situation of the Trump Hotel
in his financial disclosures, received undisclosed
preferential treatment from a foreign bank
on a $170 million loan to the hotel that the
president personally guaranteed accepted millions
of dollars in emoluments from foreign governments
without providing an accounting of the moneys
source or purpose concealed hundreds of millions
of dollars in debts from GSA when bidding
on the Old Post Office building lease and
made it impossible for GSA to properly enforce
the leases conflict of interest restrictions
by engaging in opaque transactions with other
affiliated entities.
As discussed in this letter, this new evidence
raises many questions that require further
investigation and action by the committee.
This is a crazy amount of alleged wrongdoing
and unethical behavior.
It it it is stunning the degree to which this
was taking place, which we knew she wasn't
aware of.
We knew this was going on.
We knew it wasn't being investigated seriously,
and it was obvious that this was going on.
He was never.
He never took care of the all of those.
Those conflicts of interest is absolutely
wild.
A few, OK, so the documents show.
Look at the specifics here.
Former President Trump reported massive revenues
at the Trump Hotel, concealing that the hotel
suffered $70 million in net losses on his
federally mandated financial disclosures.
Trump reported that the hotel earned him over
one hundred and fifty million in revenue during
his time in office.
But the records obtained show it actually
incurred losses of 70 million, leading Trump's
holding company to inject at least 24 million
into the struggling hotel by filing misleading
public disclosures.
Trump exaggerated the health of the hotel.
He also appears to have concealed potential
conflicts of interest stemming not just from
his ownership of this failing business, but
also from his roles as the hotel's lender
and guarantor of its third party loans.
While in office, Trump received preferential
treatment, potentially worth millions from
a foreign bank.
It is Deutsche Bank.
Deutsche Bank is endlessly involved every
single time there's a new report about these
conflicts.
Deutsche Bank is involved.
Trump did not publicly disclose the benefits
he got.
It's a deferral that he got.
The Trump Hotel received over $3.7 million
from foreign governments.
We knew that foreign governments were staying
at Trump's D.C. hotel specifically to curry
favor with him and to ingratiate themselves
with him.
We now know it is to the tune of $3.7 million
that is about 7400 nights at Trump Hotel at
the average daily rate.
Trump didn't disclose that to the GSA, and
he donated to the Treasury only a small portion
of those payments.
And then it goes on and on.
Funny business where the lease related to
the old post office building and much, much
more.
This is more of the same stuff that he's been
doing and getting away with for his whole
career.
He has bragged about it.
He says he knows how to work the system.
He knows how to essentially ignore regulations
and laws.
And we knew he was doing it on day one, where
he showed up with the big stack of paper and
said, Here's the paperwork that my attorneys
are filing in order to deal with my conflicts
of interest.
And we were like, Ah, the ah, first of all,
ah, is the stack even of is, are they blank
papers?
Was the obvious question one.
And number two, are they substantively meaningful
in terms of actually dealing with conflicts
of interest?
And it obviously they were not.
This should all be investigated, as many of
these seem violations of the four Foreign
Corrupt Practices Act, which says it's unlawful
for a U.S. person or company to offer, pay
or promise to pay money or anything of value
to foreign officials for the purposes of obtaining
or retaining business.
This seems to have been violated two ways
back and forth for lack of a better term.
This is it.
It's it's the frustrating part is obviously
this was going on.
Obviously, it was going on, and now it could
take, as we've been predicting, for the better
part of this year already.
It could take years to unwind and uncover
everything that went on, and we probably won't
ever really learn the full extent of it.
So incredible revelations here and we'll continue
to follow them up.